la région de Montréal.♪
- Le trafic a repris au chemin
Roxham, à la frontière canado-
américaine.
En quelques années, c'est
devenu un des principaux points
au pays.
Après la pause pandémique,
e reprise qui a
des répercussions dans
les écoles du Grand MontréalATHe
intercult., Marie-Victorin
- L'année scolaire 2019-2020,
c'était vraiment une année
record, de l'accueil des demands
d'asile. Depuis la réouvertu
du chemin Roxham, on a
l'impression de reprendre
- Ça veut dire : quel jour ou
quel moi
- L'accueil des enfants
immigrants et allophones pourliu
jusqu'en juin.
Depuis janvier, le Centre de
services scolaires de Montréal
a inscride quoi de quoi de quoie
primaire.
Des élèves arrivés comme
immigrants avec leurs parents,yi
un grand nombre de réfugiés
plus vulnérables.
- Dès qu'il y a une reprise
au chemion le sent
quelques jours, voire quelques
semaines plus tard,
les210 enfants qu'on a reçusau e
ces enfants-là venaient de
quatre pays, donc,ue, Haïti, lae
et le Brésil.
les inscriptions sont
à la hausse aussi.
- On a plus de demandeurs
d'asile la pandéla pandéla pands
qui nous arrivent doublement
vulnérabilisés de par le fait
qu'ils ont pas été scolarisés
parce qu'ils n'ont pas eu
le temps de préparer leurer leur
parcours migratoire. Ils n'ont
pas choisi, souvent, le pays.
- Est-ce que tout le monde a
compris?- L'enseignante Isabelld
est aux premières loges dans
sa classe d'accueil du Centre de
services scolaires de la Pointe
de l'Ile. Elle vient de prendre
une adolescente ukrainienne sous
son aile.
ISABELLE BUJOLD, enseignante
classe d'accueil, Anjou
- Moi, c'est ma 13n
a eu les élèves du tremblement
de terre en Haïti. T'sais, on
a eu des Afghans, on a eu des
Syriens, on a eu des élèves,
ui ont passé par le
chemin Roxham, qui ont traversé
l'Amérique à pied, qui sont
partis du Brésil. On a des
élèves qui ont perdu des membres
de leur famille en chemin, là.
Donc, on a quand même de
l'expérience avec des élèves
qui ont vécu toutes sortes
de traumas.
- Les élèves peuvent passer un
ou deux ans en classe d'accueil
avant d' une classe
régulière.
- La classe d'accueil porte
super bien son nom parce que
c'est vraiment un endroit pour
accueillir les éleves,
un endroit de transition,
un endroit chaleureux pour
dire : bienvenue chez vous,
finalement.
RÉGINALD FLEURY, conseiller
pédago., interculturelles,
- On a de quoi être fiers là-
dessus. C'est qu'on aide
nnée des milliers
d'élèves à apprendre
le français. Pour nos élèves
qui arrivent au primaire,
c'est fascinant à quel point
ils apprennent rapidement.
- Mais c'est un système qui fait
face aussi aux mêmes défis que
l'ensemble du réseau scolaire :
une rareté de main-d'oeuvre.
- Ça prend des classes, mais
ça prend aussi des enseignants.
- J'ai peur qu'on ait perdu
beaucoup d'expertise. À cause
de la pandémie, les fermetures
des frontières, il y a
plein de profs qui se sont
retrouvés dans des classes
ordinaires. J'espère que
ces profs-là vont revenir.
- On se prépare maintenant
à accueillir des élèves
ukrainiens.
Ici Anne-Louise Despaties,
Radio-Canada, Mont